what is the new battlestar galactica
series going to be about
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so we know that there is a new battle
star galactica series coming there's
actually also going to be a movie
but what is the series going to be about
how are they going to make it different
while still existing within ronald d
moore's universe as promised
ronaldi moore has already rebooted the
battlestar galactica series and created
something that really does still stand
up
so sam esmel and i completely agree with
him
doesn't want to mess with that he wants
to keep that as canon and do a series
that is within that universe
[Music]
this is the commander
moments ago this ship received word of a
cylon attack against our home worlds is
underway
we do not know the size or the
disposition or the strength of the enemy
forces
but all indications point
to a massive assault
against colonial defenses
how do we do something that's different
but still
within canon so i do have a little bit
of an idea and i think some ismail
accidentally has given us a bit of a
hint on what they intend to do so in an
interview a few months ago sam esmell
was talking about how they actually plan
to on the peacock network release this
series a little bit differently
they've basically realized that on a
streaming service you can release the
episodes any way you like they can do it
all in one go they could do it in little
drips and drabs they could do it on one
day a week they could do whatever they
want
so why not do it a way that actually
adds something to the story and at one
point he says there's going to be a big
battle sequence and over three episodes
we're going to see that battle from
three different perspectives
this is going to be a classic defeat
spoken of throughout the star system for
a thousand yards
launch fighters
[Music]
but what could those three perspectives
be
well it makes sense that one would be
the humans refugees trying to escape the
silent war but that's been done so how
do they do something bit different with
that but it makes sense that would be
one of the perspectives
one perspective is obviously going to be
a cylon perspective the attackers well
to consider what the third aspect could
be we have to consider the cylinders on
what we know
right so the cylons were constructed by
man
there was a war they left the cylons
believe in one god they're monotheistic
the humans believe in multiple gods an
interesting twist that ronald d moore
found quite funny when he did the
original series because normally in
these types of things
the
people that believe in multiple gods are
the bad guys and the good guys are the
ones that believe in one god
so and it's a little twister but the
silence believe that they need to
eradicate humanity before they can
really become in touch with their god
because they believe
that god made humanity and made them
imperfect but then
through humanity built the cylons to be
closer to that perfection now the cylons
have at times tried to create hybrids
that are part human part cylon
there was a whole breeding program by
one of the seven
and even as far back as the first cylon
war the silence were trying to do this
the cylon hybrids that control and are
the heart of all base stars originally
were humans taken kidnapped during the
original asylum war and basically
experimented upon
the cylons though had gone on to
continue that experimentation through
sexual hybridization actually breeding
hybrids with humans
so could it be that the third
perspective is one of these hybrids
perhaps a hybrid on a base star reaches
a different kind of consciousness
because we also know that within the
cylon hierarchy they didn't always agree
for example number two or leo von conoy
said that the hybrids could hear god
that they were closer to god somehow
now if they believe that as part of
their religion
perhaps the hybrids that were very
strange characters the hybrids within
the base stars were very strange
characters they would have almost levels
of orgasmic pleasure when the ship sort
of did things like going to war and go
to light speed and then go did light
jumps lists of dreams drip along the
nascent echo
and love no more
jump
counting down all functions nominal
while function's optimal counting down
the center holds
but they also seem to be controlling the
centurions in some way in one episode we
see a hybrid being disconnected from the
base star and when he does the
centurions seem to
lose control lose power
die even
so
could we see a scenario where a hybrid
either a bread hybrid species maybe a
ship that's just full of hybrids or a
hybrid from a bay star
changes their mind about this decision
to wipe out humanity and maybe sees the
people the humans as god's children
something that may be instead of being
exterminated should be protected
the whole series then could be a very
strange mix
of the cylons that are then protecting
humanity
trying to decide what to do they're in a
turmoil can you imagine actually
centurions wandering around the humans
not knowing what the hell to do about it
and how to deal with that
i mean i could see that actually being
really interested there's elements of
humor potentially there possible because
you know the people trying to figure out
what the hell to do with this new
scenario all of a sudden their mortal
enemy actually protecting them
they're
really interesting moral stories there
and you know ways to explore morality
and what it is to be human potentially
it could expand upon this whole cylon
mythos about their religion and we could
see that from a different angle as well
this theory could be a really
interesting way for or still to have
series it is battlestar galactica they
will still feel like battlestar
galactica but at the same time
that little bit different
jump
a slightly different aspect on a similar
story within the same universe because
there is nothing to say that within what
we've seen of balsa galactic or ronaldi
moore's battlestar galactica that more
humans didn't survive somewhere else
but we cannot have the same series again
we cannot have another battle star with
another bunch of refugees trying to
escape the cylons now there are other
battle stars we know about the pegasus
and things like this but that's been
done they need to do something different
so just maybe
this is a way they could go
so guys get into the comments tell me
what you think is this a theory that has
just come at the top of my head and is
utter madness or is it something that
you'd actually like to see
or is there another idea that you've got
that you would love to see get in the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification thumbs up thumbs down helps
nobody and if you want to become a fully
fledged sidetracker you can consider
hitting that join button it really
supports the channel
as always please guys stay safe i'll see
you soon
[Music]
you